افاد موقع المرشد الايراني يعني ان سلطانه
عمان هيثم بن طارق نقل له رغبه مصر في
استئناف العلاقات مع ايران وضف الموقعنا
خامنيين رحب خلال لقائه سلطانه عمان في
طهران بفكره استئناف العلاقات مع مصر
وبشان العلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه قال
المرشد الايراني انها جاءت نتيجه للسياسه
الايجابيه التي تتبعها طهران لتعزيز
علاقاتها بدور الجوار وشر خامني الى ان
سياسه اسرائيل وداعمها تستهدف زعزعه
الاستقرار في المنطقه حسب تعبيره
انما من مسقط الدكتور محمد العريمي رئيس
جمعيه الصحفيين العمريين الاستاذ محمد
دكتور محمد ما الذي حمله سلطان عمان معه
في هذه الزياره
نعم حقيقه زياره السلطان هيثم بن طارق
سلطان عمان لايران تحمل في طياتها العديد
من الملفات منها حقيقه ما هو محلي صرف
مختص بالاقتصاد والاستثمار والتبادل
التجاري بين البلدين ومنها ما هو اقليمي
ودولي كما ذكرت بالفعل هناك ملفات عالقه
حقيقه في المنطقه وهي ليست مخفيه على
المتتبعين للشان السياسي الاقليمي منها
الملف اليمني وعديده الملفات طبعا قبل
سبعه ايام قام السلطان هيثم بزياره الى
جمهوريه مصر العربيه واجتمع مع فخامه
الرئيس المصري
واستمعنا حقيقه للعديد من وسائل
الاعلام المختصه وايضا هناك بعض التصاريح
بان هناك وساطه
مصريه
لاعاده الحياه السياسيه والاعاده العلاقات
السياسيه كما كانت عليه قبل سنوات عديده
بين مصر
وايران هناك كانت تبادل زيارات عديده على
مستويات عاليه ورفيعه بين عمان ومصر وايضا
بين عمان وايران واستطيع القول بان عمان
نجحت دبلوماسيه العمانيه نجحت او ساعدت في
اعاده العلاقه السعوديه الايرانيه وهي
سياسه موثوق فيها في المنطقه
ودائما من مسعى عمان وسياسه عمان لمحاوله
احلال السلام في المنطقه
هل سنرى مخرجات لهذه الزياره واهم مضيق
الانعكاس لهذه الزياره اقليميه
اعتقد شخصيا كمتابع سياسي نعم هناك مؤشرات
ايجابيه ليس على مستوى المصري وايضا
الايراني او السعودي الايراني هناك مؤشرات
وتحولات اقليميه كما هو معلوم اعتقد على
دول المنطقه جميعها ان
تستفيد من هذه التحولات وتخلق نوع من
العلاقه السياسيه السينما وان امتداد
العشرين سنه الماضيه اثبت بان هذه
التوترات وهذه التنازعات لن تاتي بايجاب
لا على هذا الطرف او ذاك شخصيا اعتقد بان
المنطقه مقبله على التحولات ايجابيه
القوه السياسيه والانظمه السياسيه سواء
كانت خليجيه او اقليميه تاعي هذه الفرصه
وتحاول جاهده ان تبني عليها علاقات خلال
الفتره القادمه لاحظنا الحرا سياسي
المتسارع بين ايران وبين السعوديه واعتقد
ان الاشهر القادمه ستشهد انفراجه كبيره في
العلاقه المصريه الايرانيه
التي سمعنا اليها سمعنا عنها قبل قليل ما
الذي يمكن بالتالي ان يكون قد انجز خلال
هذه الزياره يبدو ان هناك تجاوب واضح
وصريح من ايران على هذه المسائل الايرانيه
انا انا انا انا شخصيا اعتقد من خلال
خبرتي في الدبلوماسيه العمانيه
الدبلوماسيه العمانيه لا تتحرك في اي
اتجاه الا اذا كان هناك رغبه مشتركه لدى
الاطراف المتنازعه او الاطراف التي بينها
مشكله قبل سبعه ايام السلطان كان في مصر
وهذا له دلاله ايجابيه الان ينتقل من مصر
الى ايران خلال فتره ليست بالكبيره نتحدث
عن سبعه ايام وبالتالي اعتقد شخصيا كمتابع
سياسي شكرا
سياسي اعتقد بان الاسابيع القادمه ستشهد
انفراجها في العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
السياسيه بين القاهره وطهران
رئيس الجمعيه الصحفيين العمريين متحدثا
الينا من مسقط